l'accueil est triomphal il prend même
des allures de victoire
mais pour en arriver là l'entraîneur des
bleus le rappelle le soutien du public
est essentielle un avantage aussi c'est
une forme de pression voilà je suis le
public berrichon chauffe ses mains et sa
voix pour encourager ses joueuses de
coeur elles ont quasiment tout défendu
les couleurs de bourges dans leur
carrière
ces acteurs du basket
je pense qu'on n'est pas les trois
quarts est passé par bourges donc on
s'est vraiment l'impact tout ça on sait
enfin que ça assure de carrière sur en
garde que les bons souvenirs
moi c'est vrai que voilà le fait d'être
bio par au cra dose ça m'a rappelé ouais
tout ce que j'ai vécu avec ces cas mais
ça fait vraiment plaisir d'être sur
plaisir partagé par les berruyers
séances photos et dédicaces
farce ce gentil les supporters sont
totalement envoûté à sa souriante fait
trouve bien je pense que ça va être beau
on sera là jeudi samedi donc on sera
derrière elle tout est long tous être
déjà cédé belle personne elles sont bien
dans leur tête c'est des filles qui sont
équilibrées qui ont le respect la
tolérance en plus et malgré tous ces
compliments
la capitaine de l'équipe de france garde
la tête bien sur les épaules avec deux
objectifs ne pas décevoir les gens qui
seront là pour nous pour nous soutenir
et ensuite avec c'est qu'on a quand même
un objectif à atteindre l'objectif qu'on
s'est fixé à la calypso audio donc avoir
la télé c'est de réussir un petit peu
tout ça les bleus repartent comme elles
sont arrivées à clamer par le public
elles auront besoin de cette chaleur
pour affronter l'australie jeudi